almost all American journalism is
controlled by a few massive corporations
news voice is a one-of-a-kind mobile app
that tracks the bias and corporate
interests that infuse the news stories
we consume every day and it's completely
free to use go to news voice dot-com
slash Pakman to download it
I have something great and horrible for
you today and it's a case study in how
an unfounded totally speculative panic
causing conspiracy theory can get itself
going and how Fox News helps Republicans
do it
wacky extremist Republican Senator Tom
cotton went on Fox Business and was
interviewed by Trump brown-noser Maria
Bartiromo
about the coronavirus we've covered
coronavirus it's an infectious disease
which originated it's believed at a
market in Wuhan China many countries
including the United States are dealing
with some cases less deadly
percentage-wise than SARS but many more
cases than SARS and it's a real issue
with serious consequences cotton goes on
Fox Business and says listen that Wuhan
market is close to a Chinese lab where
we don't know what they're doing and
Maria Bartiromo keeps it going with
questions like wait we don't know what
they're doing there wait the lab is
right near the market that is supposedly
the source of the corona virus and of
course there's no evidence for anything
that Tom cotton is implying here check
out this irresponsible screed and then
we'll discuss it have to get to the
bottom of that we also know that just a
few miles away from that food market is
China's only biosafety level 4 super
laboratory that researches human
infectious diseases now we don't have
evidence that this disease originated
there but because of China's duplicity
and dishonesty from the beginning we
need to at least ask the question to see
what the evidence says and China right
now is not giving any evidence on that
question at all
so this super lab that you refer to this
super lab is the only one of its kind in
this area in Wuhan and the province that
that area and and what do they do at
this super lab it's unclear Maria we
have such laboratories ourselves in the
United States run by our military in
large part done for preventive purposes
or trying to discover vaccines or to
protect our own soldiers China is
obviously very secretive about what
happens at the Wuhan laboratory we don't
know again where this virus originated
that's why it's so important that we at
least ask the questions and get the
evidence but China continues to block
our ability to ask those questions and
get that evidence so the key line there
is we don't have evidence that the
disease originated in this lab that's
actually all you need to say that should
end the conversation but Maria Bartiromo
says you're saying this is the only lab
like it in China and it's right there
next to the Wuhan market and he says
yeah and we don't even know what it is
that they do at this lab well that's
also not evidence of anything and Maria
Bartiromo should do the responsible
thing and say senator is there any
evidence for what you're implying here
and the answer would be no instead Maria
Bartiromo says wow the only lab of its
kind right there just stoking this
totally fact-free conspiracy theory from
Tom cotton Tom cotton is citing this
vague circumstantial thing while during
the Russia probe days remember that Tom
cotton didn't find it circumstantially
suspicious that endless members of
trumps team had contact with Russians
and lied about it and tried to hide it
that was a circumstantial case not at
all suspicious to Tom cotton here
totally without evidence suggesting that
the latest flu-like disease may be a
Chinese bioweapon not only willing to
put it out there but helped along by
Maria Bartiromo
on Fox Business now in case you care
this idea has already been discussed and
debunked it is true that there is a well
known lab in whoo-hah
it's a cell cellular level biosafety
level 4 lab there is a statement from
Richard a bright professor of chemical
biology at Rutgers who says quote
there's absolutely nothing in the genome
sequence of this virus that indicates
the virus was engineered the possibility
this was a deliberately released bio
weapon can be firmly excluded now
additionally why would the Chinese
create a bio weapon that is mostly
killing Chinese people is a question but
then Tom Cotton's sort of tries to
backtrack and says well I'm not saying
it was developed on purpose in the lab
but maybe accidentally tweeting a number
of possibilities we're number two was
good science bad safety in other words
they were researching things like
diagnostic testing and vaccines but an
accidental breach occurred once again
it's hugely irresponsible if Republicans
are furious that sitting senator Amy
Klobuchar didn't know the name of the
Mexican president we talked about that
yesterday then they should be endlessly
more furious that a sitting senator Tom
cotton is eagerly willing to spread
panic and disinformation like this they
don't care they don't care and Tom
cotton continues to do it helped along
by the way by Fox News's Maria Bartiromo
who was she used to be a good financial
reporter interviewing CEOs on the floor
of the New York Stock Exchange 15 years
ago when I started getting into the
stock market 20 years ago even she has
become a trump brown-nose brown-noser
and perpetuator of disinformation that
that is it's sad and also very
frustrating to see because she could
still be a good journalist and instead
she does this stuff